Immigration.
It's a scary word.
And scarier when I say
it like this:
-(softly): Immigration.
-(laughter)
But libs want to take anyone in.
Your tired, your poor,
your huddled masses.
It's completely un-American.
Luckily, General John Kelly,
Trump's chief of staff, gets it.
Kind of the norm. Yeah. Yeah.
Immigrants need to be educated.
Skilled workers who know English
and have a rockin' bod.
Okay, he didn't say
the last one,
but I think it was implied.
But of course,
the libs were ready
to jump on Kelly's
so-called "hypocrisy." Look.
General Kelly's own family,
from the Brighton section
of Boston,
uh, his father was Irish,
his mother was Italian,
his great-grandfather
was a wagon driver
who was reportedly
a illiterate Italian,
didn't speak English.
His maternal, um, grandmother
had a fruit cart.
See? John Kelly's ancestors
were exactly the kind
of high achievers
he wants in America.
In those days,
wagon driver and fruit peddler
were basically CEO
and iPhone inventor.
(laughter)
The point is, back then
immigrants had merit.
And here to agree with me is
citizen-journalist Kobi Libii.
-Now, Kobi...
-(cheering, applause)
Now, Kobi, you are
an expert in history.
Correct, Jordan.
I'm histrionic.
And John Kelly's right--
America has a longstanding
immigration policy
called "no scrubs."
We only let in
highly skilled people.
The first Thanksgiving
was actually just the Pilgrims
partying after they finished
their PhD dissertation.
Wow. Those Native Americans
must have learned so much
from them about farming corn
and not freezing in winter.
Big-time. And the Irish who came
over during the potato famine
were all doctors.
In their careful study
of nutrition and the human body,
they discovered that not eating
is bad for you.
Wow. Incredible research.
Now, groups this well-educated
must have been immediately
accepted into American life.
Absolutely! That's why
you'll never hear a mean joke
-about a Polish person.
-Never heard one.
So, these immigrants
had something to offer
and achieved the American dream.
Without a doubt,
because the American dream
is coming over
with established wealth
and a marketable trade,
and then pretty much staying
exactly where you are.
Otherwise, you're a scrub.
And you can't get no love
from me.
You see, America is exclusive.
We're like the Harvard
of countries.
-There's a quota on Asians.
-Uh, well, yes,
but also,
not everyone can get in.
You might get waitlisted,
or you might have to go
to your safety country,
which, funnily enough
for asylum seekers,
is much less safe.
So, if you want
to get out of a war zone
and get into America,
first you just need
to get a masters
from your war zone university
in math or science
or the politics
of surviving a genocide,
and then you can immigrate
to America
once you have skills,
real skills.
-Valuable skills. -Not too many
skills, though, Jordan.
Then they'll take our jobs.
Okay. So, okay, so...
(cheering and applause)
Let me get this...
So, okay, yeah.
So we want just the right level
of skills--
-not too many, not too few.
-Like Goldilocks.
Okay, now, that's...
that's an immigrant
I can get behind.
Cute, sweet, hates nature.
And something
about her blonde hair
just fits with my idea
of America.
Yeah, well, well, that's
the ultimate skill, Jordan:
looking like you fit in.
Just ask John Kelly's
great-grandparents.
But make sure
you do it in Italian,
'cause they don't speak a word
of English.
Yes. Thanks, Kobi.
The fight continues.